that turned out to be quite the dramatic
ending among us yeah i did um i thought
i'd sort of tricked him when i sacked
the
exchange there i thought after that my
pawns were just running uh and then
he dug in he sort of found the defense
and i couldn't really see a way to break
through so
what i went for was kind of my last
trick but it worked but it seemed to be
two players a little bit confused about
what to do with a very lonely pawns
forward time there
yeah it was um
it was a super
complicated and weird position i mean i
suspect that was a lot better but
i couldn't really see i couldn't really
see how
and i wasn't so sure about my prospects
if i didn't play dynamically so i tried
to play dynamically but got a little bit
out of hand
but at least you know i'm trying to play
trying to play complicated chess but
it's
yeah it's um
tiring but um i finally got rewarded you
know mistakes don't usually happen in a
in a vacuum so
um obviously it was under a lot of
pressure for a lot of time or for a long
time there does that mean that we may
see yet another game four that is
complicated and fun and exciting or are
you going to try to hit the brakes we'll
see um
it's a little bit up to to him as well i
mean there are several approaches
that you can go for when trying to play
for a win so let's see good luck thank
you